I see, but
all the
mysteries have been
solved.
Heart Nekokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokomosakinokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokomosaikokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokokomosa
(music)
What do you
mean, you have a dog in your house in June
, like your older brother, but you're just
a rival to thank you for everything up until now
Shake switch, and your desire to monopolize is on the surface
Oh
, I don't think the way of speaking or gestures are similar.
I
honestly don't feel like I'm being spoiled at all Well, put on a
nice pattern
Don't you have a nice one
?  -
It can't be helped
[Music]
Jarren I
'm sorry I ended up like that -
Furukoshi -
Hmm